-Guys, you all know
how to play charades.
Each player gets a turn
giving silent clues
to their teammate.
30 seconds on the clock
per turn.
We'll do four rounds,
and then the fifth round
is a charades showdown.
Both teams give the same clue
at the same time.
Zendaya, why don't you start us
off tonight?
-Oh, no pressure.
Okay.
-Yeah, no pressure at all, yeah.
Billy, you and Tariq
will sit here on Team Billy,
and I'm Team Jimmy, so.
-I'm right here?
I'm going?
-There you go, yeah.
And whatever --
You guys want to help give
a number?
[ Audience shouting
suggestions ]
-A guy just yelled "Tariq."
That's helpful.
-I'm gonna go with three.
-All right. Yep.
-Lucky number.
Okay.
-Three, lucky number.
Here we go.
We can do this.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Okay.
-[ Clears throat ]
-Oh, you can put it
in that little thing.
Yeah.
Here we go.
It's a song.
-Okay.
-Yes.
-Um...
-Three, four, five words.
Oh, boy.
First word, the.
No, I.
I will always love you.
[ Laughter ]
I....see.
No, look.
I see through you.
I -- Ooh.
I picture -- Ooh.
I -- Glare.
I stare.
I stab.
I-I slaughter.
I ripped.
Chainsaw.
"I Saw Mommy Kissing
Santa Claus!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That is good.
That is how you do it
right there!
Get ready, man.
-I know.
-Get ready.
I can see you're intimidated.
You're intimidated, man.
I can tell you're intimidated.
Yeah, because I can see
your p-p-p-poker face.
All right, let's go.
Come on.
You're up, buddy.
Good luck.
-It's just focus, Jimmy.
It's just focus.
That's all it is.
-I know what it is. Yeah.
-Lucky number.
-One!
-One.
-Oh, one. That was quick.
-Wow. Wow, wow, wow.
He is focused.
He's a focused individual.
Okay.
He looks -- He looks concerned.
But now he's --
Yeah, he's looking
a little confident.
-It's a movie.
Three words.
The third word.
Song.
Uh, sing.
I want to sing.
I'm singing.
I'm singing in the rain.
I...
Okay, second word.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, ring.
"The Wedding Singer."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
B-B-B-B-Bow!
-[ Laughs ]
You know what I'm saying?
You don't have to be that calm
where you're like,
"Oh, 'The Wedding Singer.'"
And then you go, "B-B-B-Bow!"
That's the silliest thing.
Billy, well done.
-That was very good.
-All right. All right.
All right.
We can do this, pal.
We got this.
-Okay.
-All right?
That took them way too long.
All right.
Give me a number, guys.
[ Audience shouting
suggestions ]
Doesn't matter.
[ Shouting continues ]
Ah!
Gosh.
-That's never good. That's --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
-Okay.
-Okay, okay, okay.
-Uh, okay.
-Okay.
-This is great.
-No, we're all fine
with you starting.
[ Laughter ]
-This is fantastic.
This is just --
I'm so excited about this,
and thank you so much
for coming over.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, you ready for this?
-Ready.
Okay.
It's a movie.
Two words.
First word.
Baby.
Second word.
"Baby Driver."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow.
Wasn't that great?
-You scared me.
You scared me.
-I know, I know, but that
was good. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Where we at?
Where we at, folks?
-I was just a little scared,
like, "How do I" --
and then I was thinking
about the movie.
And I was like "Oh,
it's 'Baby Driver.'"
[ Audience shouting
suggestions ]
-I'm gonna go four.
-All right, four.
-"Fever Pitch."
-Oh, my God.
This is ridi--
-Movie.
-This is ridiculous.
-"Taxi."
One word.
-[ Laughs ]
-Zombie.
Monster.
-Yeah, the movie --
-"Frankenstein."
-The famous movie "Zombie."
-"Dracula."
-You're flying.
Are you flying?
One word.
-Yeah, it's only one word.
So, you're -- "You are flying"
is three words.
-Uh...
-Very -- Very close.
It's one word, though, Billy.
That's the only problem.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, that's the issue here.
-Yeah, "You are flying"
is a good guess, though.
-Lift.
Lifting.
Uplift.
Uh, curve.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
[ Sad trombone plays ]
-Ready?
Do that that again.
-Shut up.
-Just do it -- No, I --
-It was "Ghost."
-I was gonna get behind you
and go
♪ Oh, my love ♪
He's making pottery.
He was making pottery.
-Yeah.
-No, thank God
you were making pottery.
[ Laughter ]
-I just got -- I just got --
I went to a different place.
-No, it's okay.
-I blew it, Tariq.
I blew that one.
-Billy, Zendaya, you guys both
give the clue at the same time
and whoever partner
gets this first
wins a million points
and wins the whole game,
so the pressure's on.
So, anyone could win this.
-It could have been
"Taxi," though,
or -- or "Fever Pitch."
-"Fever Pitch" is two words.
"Taxi."
-I was thinking vase.
-And "Fever Pitch."
Thank you, Billy,
for being a fan.
-Yeah, I was trying to think
of some of your other movies.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience shouting
suggestions ]
-All right.
-I don't know.
-Oh, my gosh.
-What number?
Seven.
-Seven?
That's what I was thinking, too.
-Uh-huh.
It's a good card.
-Okay.
-Oh, no, why did my partner
just --
Put me a little thought
into this one.
Yeah, Billy,
you seem ready to go.
-I'm trying to think
how I'm going to do this.
-You ready?
-Okay.
-All right, here we go.
-Song.
-Song, yep.
-Two words.
-First word.
Uh, shark.
Shark attack.
Shark b-- Chomp.
Bite.
Eat you.
-Dragon.
-Attack.
-Crocodile.
Crocodile tears.
Crocodile.
-Croc -- Uh, alli--
"Crocodile Rock."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-He helped us!
He helped us!
-He helped us.
Yeah, we got it!
-Yeah. Good job.
-[ Laughs ]
-Good job.
-Yo, that's how to do it
right there.
Zendaya right there.
The champ.
Billy Crudup
and Tariq Trotter right there.